we've already talked a good bit about
open end and closed and fun and you
might say hey maybe there's something in
between the open end fund had the
advantage of being able to grow the
actual net asset value just for more
investors coming in the closed-end fund
but there's a disadvantage there's that
you had to keep some cash on hand if
people got scared a bunch of people
might leave the fund of the fund will
shrink forcing it to sell assets
possibly the worst possible time on a
closed-end fund the the weakness is that
it was kind of a fixed net asset value
so the fund manager might not like it
even if they're doing good more and more
people can't pile on at least on a
typical basis but the benefit is is that
these these shares right over here when
people do want liquidity they do want
their money back instead of having to
transact with the open end fund and the
open and fund having to keep all that
cash on hand and all of the expenses of
the transaction they could just trade it
on a market and there is indeed
something in between it's called an
exchange-traded fund exchange
exchange-traded exchange-traded fund
referred to often referred to as ETS ETF
for short an exchange-traded fund like
an open end mutual fund so let's say
there's an exchange-traded fund right
over here and these are has a bunch of
shares it has a bunch of shares it has
some net asset value in an
exchange-traded fund like a closed-end
fund these shares these shares can be
traded on an exchange traded on exchange
and for the typical investor just
wanting to buy one share or redeem one
share they're not allowed to do it on
their own and so that frees the
exchange-traded fund from some of this
overhead that the open ended the open
end mutual fund has to worry about about
always keeping this cash on hand the
overhead of having to transact between
its shareholders on a daily basis but
the way that an exchange-traded fund
kind of compromises and still allows
itself to grow or even possibly shrink
is it will do new share issuances in
bulk and an open-ended fund it would be
one share at a time and an
exchange-traded fund they will do it in
bulk so they will do it only with
certain parties parties who can transact
in
huge volumes and one of these parties
can say okay I want another million
shares so they will buy another 1
million they will create another 1
million shares sell it to the
appropriate party and then that will
increase that will increase their net
asset value so what does this do for the
exchange-traded fund well they have none
of this overhead of these redemptions
every day with the smaller investors
they can only do it in bulk so this
means that they have lower expenses
lower expenses which means that they can
pass it on to the shareholders and have
lower fees lower fees they are also not
actively managed so they tend to not be
actively managed not actively actively
managed which once again drives lower
expenses so they can have lower fees
what do I mean by not actively managable
an open-end fund will typically say hey
we're great stock investors we can do
better than the market by investing in
us you're gonna get a team of
researchers you know you've seen the
commercials on TV where they they're
analyzing companies and they're getting
on planes around the globe and looking
very worldly an ETF says well look we
think that we can't do any better than
the market we're not gonna actively
manage we're just gonna take the assets
and buy let's say all the stocks
weighted appropriately of the S&P S&P
500 or maybe it's an exchange-traded
fund for some type of a commodity we're
gonna take all these assets and buy some
type of a commodity like like gold and
that's useful for someone for the
shareholder because it's very hard for
an individual to get the diversification
of the S&P 500 to buy all of the shares
and the appropriate weighting and keep
reading it and it's also hard for an
individual investor to buy a little bit
of gold or even a lot of gold and store
the gold and sell the gold and secure
the gold and so the exchange-traded fund
can do it in an appropriate in an
appropriate way now one question that
you might be having is outside of these
large bulk transactions that create or
redeem the shares that already exist in
the exchange or the that create more
shares the shares are being traded on
exchange and we talked about closed-end
funds we talked about because they're
traded on an exchange and you can't
create
or redeem any new shares typically the
shares could trade at a premium or at a
discount to their net asset value now
what would be the case for an
exchange-traded fund an exchange-traded
fund they actually typically trade very
close to net asset value so trade trade
very close to net asset value so why do
these exchange-traded funds close trade
close trade close to net asset value
while closed and fun stone when a
closed-end fund there's no easy way to
arbitrage even if it's trading at a
significant discount you can't buy those
shares and then somehow try to get try
to redeem those shares for the net asset
value and in the turn in the in the case
of an ETF some of these large
shareholders these large trans actors
these people who the ETF will transact
with could do it if these traded in a
discount if these trade trade at a
discount if these traded at a discount
what you would have happening is a large
a large number of these of these these
the the larger the larger I would say
dealers could buy a bunch of them at a
discount and then redeem them with the
actual fund itself and then they would
make a profit similarly if it traded if
it traded at a if it traded at a premium
the the the large dealers could create
could buy more shares so the the
exchange-traded fund could create more
shares and then they could sell it at a
premium to net asset value and they
essentially make pretty close to
risk-free money and so because there's
this arbitrage opportunity arbitrage
opportunity with exchange-traded funds
they tend to trade very very very close
to net asset value and oftentimes
because it's very transparent what
they're doing here that they're either
buying the S&P 500 the Nasdaq or gold or
oil it's very clear what the NASA net
asset value is or very close to what it
is even during the trading day